we've gone through the basics of
morphemes and covered a few word classes
now we move on to a part of speech known
as the adjective you're probably aware
that adjectives describe nouns but you
might not have considered their function
from a morphological perspective
sometimes they work more like nouns and
sometimes they're more like verbs let's
start with some examples in ancient
Greek adjectives decline exactly like
nouns do in fact they routinely take the
same endings for a number gender and
case since that's true we can see
examples like OD Kos anthropos the just
person or the fair person versus headach
iagoo net which would mean the just
woman or the fair woman and in that case
we have an opposition between D chaos
which is masculine singular and
nominative as well and dakea which is
feminine singular and nominative in both
situations we have an adjective
describing a noun but they're working
like a noun declining like a noun now
I'll draw a counter example from
Japanese in Japanese many adjectives
work a lot more like verbs in fact
they're specifically what we would call
stative verbs which are verbs that
indicate a state instead of an action so
a description like is happy or is hot
would indicate a state for example atsui
means is hot in japanese those
connectors true adjectives in front of a
noun or they can instead take the place
of a verb in languages that treat
adjectives more like nouns don't be
surprised to find them used as a noun
take the ancient Greek example I gave
you just a moment ago I can instead say
Hoda Cayuse which means literally the
just or the fair in English that would
translate to the just one or the fair
one and in that case we have D Chios
working exactly like what we would
expect a noun to work like in Greek on
the other hand in Japanese the words I
used in those sentences work exactly as
we would expect a verb to work and they
are conjugated like a Japanese verb
there's a good deal more to be said for
adjectives beyond these basics but it's
worth reviewing the lessons on nouns and
verbs to dig into their properties and
come around next time when we meet the
very versatile grammatical particle
you